[Music]
the spiderman no way home teaser has
been throwing fans around the world for
barely two weeks now this is most likely
due to the return of many familiar faces
that we can guess from the teaser among
them are the green goblin lizard sandman
electro and of course duck ock they are
all set to go up against the spiderman
played by tom holland toby maguire and
andrew garfield giving fans a true
multiverse spectacle while the many
villains are mostly confirmed there's
still no confirmation of the spider-man
trio on the good guys side garfield in
particular has denied involvement in no
way home in the past on the happy sad
confused podcast even in a more recent
conversation with variety the 38 year
old did not back down from his denial he
once again explained in detail that he
himself was a fan and that he liked the
idea of three spider-man at once but it
was also important for him to emphasize
that he was not involved in the project
in any way besides he stated that it
doesn't matter what he says because many
fans will either be very disappointed or
it will be very exciting for them so is
this now the denial that many fans were
not expecting we obviously do not
believe anything garfield is saying
because while at the very beginning of
the rumors it was still considered to be
a pipe dream to c3 spider-man on screen
by now it is regarded as almost certain
especially considering that a hint about
the antagonists of garfield and maguire
already appeared in the teaser in
addition shortly after the interview
with a variety a video surfaced that
supposedly shows garfield filming no way
home what do you think is an appearance
of tom holland toby maguire and andrew
garfield safe or does garfield's
statement make you question it feel free
to let us know in the comments
it is not the first time sony has
rescheduled the release of the upcoming
venom let there be carnage this time
however fans do not have to wait any
longer instead they can expect to see
the film in theaters at an earlier date
as variety reports the us release has
been moved up to october 1st 2021 the
reason for this is likely to be the
success of the recently released
jungxian the legend of the 10 rings
given that marvel achieved a
considerable box office result of almost
90 million us dollars in the first few
days which is not a bad amount of money
for film release in this time of
pandemic sony is hoping for a similar
result as they of course aim to achieve
the same success as with the previous
film although the recently announced ush
rating of 13 and up did not please
everyone the hype around the comic
adaption is still tremendous we're
looking forward to the face-off between
carnage and vanaman eagerly away the new
release on october 1st
the upcoming aquaman and the lost
kingdom aims to continue the franchise's
track record after the first part gross
over a billion us dollars there's no
doubt that this is very understandable
the release is still quite some time
away but we are glad to see new footage
of the sequel first of all there's a
picture of the popular main character
author curry aka aquaman in addition to
his typical clothing he wears a brand
new suit in the upcoming film which is
much darker fittingly jason memorial
comments as follows on instagram second
round new suit more action as a fan this
is of course great news and many
wondering what this suit is actually all
about after all the fancy design comes
with a handy feature that makes the
wearer invisible so we naturally assume
that the protagonist will have to act
subtly and inconspicuously in the
upcoming sequel well at least at times
there's a lot of speculation at this
point especially in connection with the
underwater kingdom of necros which will
be the focus of the plot of the second
part let's see what happens arthur curry
is not the only one to feature a new
look though as the villain side also
brings news in a picture posted by
director james juan you can see actor
patrick wilson in his role as ocean
master at first sight you might think
you're seeing a meeting between james 1
and robinson cruzo but it is in fact
wilson but all killing aside the reason
for the neglect is not quite clear yet
it could have something to do with the
focus on horror elements in the upcoming
part again we can only speculate here
aquaman and the lost kingdom will hit
theaters on december 16 2022
the huge rig and morty fan community was
quite amazed when they suddenly saw
christopher lloyd in the new teaser for
the fifth season sure rick and his
companion morty are kind of based on
doug brown and marty mcfly from the back
to the future franchise anyway but the
fact that you now get to see lioness
live-action rick is a real surprise
joining him is it star jaden martellus
morty and the regular pickle as pickle
rick okay all jokes aside many fans are
of course wondering what this is all
about since the tweet was posted before
the season finale without any context
it's hard to know whether it's just a
clever pr stunt or if the teaser might
actually reveal a clue about the finale
the only extra information is c132 which
stands for one of the parallel universes
from the rick and morty world might it
be universe where the characters are
embodied by real actors find it out for
yourself because the entire fifth season
is now available to watch as the last
two episodes came out on september 5th
work on mission impossible 7 has already
been underway since january 2019. since
then there has been one major cause for
the project to be talked about and that
is the various postponements of the
release date so to shorten the waiting
time of more than a year we thought you
might enjoy a short summary of
everything that is known about the 7th
part so far let's start with the cast
there are no big surprises at this point
we will see tom cruise as ethan hunt
being reigns as luther stickle simon
pack as benji don rebecca ferguson as
elsa faust and vanessa kirby as alanna
metzopoulos among many others making a
special return is henry cherny as eugene
kiddridge as his character has not been
on screen since the first part in 1996.
behind the camera christopher mcfory is
again the director and scriptwriter and
he and his team are responsible for the
implementation there are still no
details regarding the story but we have
already gotten a glimpse of the
breathtaking stunts of the action
blockbuster the absolute highlight is a
motorcycle jump in which lead actor tom
cruise himself falls down a huge cliff
he refers to it as the most dangerous
stunt of his life which is certainly no
understatement on the part of the 59
year old we will continue to keep you up
to date on upcoming news about mission
impossible unfortunately the release
date of september 30th 2022 is not yet
in sight
mr and mrs smith starring brad pitt and
angelina jolie was released 16 years ago
the film not only laid the foundation
for the relationship between the two
stars which later became world famous
under the name brangelina but was also
an enjoyable action romance rather
suddenly it was announced at the
beginning of the year that a mr and mrs
smith series was being planned under the
direction of showrunner francesca sloane
the two main actors were also already
confirmed mr smith wants to be embodied
by us rapper and actor donald glover
while the female counterpart was to be
given to phoebe waller bridge but as
deadline now reported a few days ago
wallabridge has abruptly quit the
project the reason is believed to have
been creative differences with her
acting colleague donald glover according
to reports the two have parted ways at
least amicably the two months-long
process of the series has now come to
sudden hold and it is now up to sloane
and glover to quickly find an adequate
replacement the situation is different
for walla bridge who is unlikely to be
bored at the moment due to the filming
of indiana jones 5. well the series is
still firmly on the schedule or whether
they might even decide to put the
project on hold is currently uncertain
as is a possible release date of course
[Music]